let's see we have two samples of helium
gas
one sample of helium gas is at t is at
temperature t1
and the other sample of helium gas is at
temperature t2
if t2 is greater than t1 that means
on average the particles of helium gas
in the second box
are moving faster than the particles of
helium gas
in the first box we can tell the
particles in the second box are moving
faster
because on average the length of these
arrows
indicating the velocity vector and the
box on the right are longer
than the length of the arrows in the
first box
the equation for kinetic energy is equal
to
one half m v squared where m
is the mass of a particle and v is the
velocity of a particle
since the gas particles in the box on
the right are on average traveling
faster and have higher velocities
the average kinetic energy of the
particles
in the box on the right is higher than
the average kinetic energy
for the particles in the box on the left
and so the average kinetic energy is
proportional to the temperature
the higher the temperature the higher
the average kinetic energy
of the particles instead of gases let's
look at two
metal blocks made of the same material
so one of the metal blocks is at
temperature t1
and the other metal block is at
temperature t2
let's say the temperature t2 is greater
than t1
what that means is the particles in the
metal box on the right
are on average moving faster than the
particles
in the metal box on the left and that
means that the average kinetic energy of
the particles in the box on the right is
greater
than the average kinetic energy in the
particles on
in the box on the left also notice right
now
our two pieces of metal are not touching
each other so there's a little bit of
space between them
next we bring the two objects and we put
them in contact with each other
so now they're collisions between the
particles that touch and this results
in the transfer of energy from the
hotter object
to the cooler object so heat flows
from the object at the higher
temperature to
the object at the lower temperature and
so the hot atoms
in on the pizza in the metal object on
the right start to move a little bit
slower
whereas the colder atoms and the metal
on the left start to move a little bit
faster
and the transfer of energy continues
until
both objects have the same final
temperature
and we say that thermal equilibrium has
been reached
so here we have our two objects and
the two objects are at the same final
temperature which means we have reached
thermal equilibrium and since we've
reached thermal equilibrium there's no
more flow of heat between the two
objects
and since both objects are at the same
final temperature that means the average
kinetic energy
of the particles in both objects is now
the same